Kyler's Murray fresh off a another great
performance roughed up tcu with four
touchdowns 25 touchdowns three
interceptions on the season his dad was
a great quarterback at Texas A&M he was
drafted and signed by the Oakland A's to
play baseball and he's up there among
the top performers for the Heisman
Trophy Cuyler Murray Oklahoma
quarterback joining us all right
official height and weight is what we're
so high the way I'd like to say I'm
giving you the real numbers I believe
510 like I mean I'm 195 right now okay
but can you can you also get more credit
by being a little bit smaller so maybe
you go five nine and three-quarters and
then people might look at these numbers
that are already impressive and say wow
look at those numbers by that guy I mean
if you want to say five my guess you
have a point I'm not just pretty
impressed with you don't wake no because
I'm a I'm not the biggest guy but
alright look at too much what's your
nickname my boys call me tell you one
simple so go smooth was it that way in
high school same nickname yes okay one I
like it
have you ever I know that in high school
you didn't lose right what are you 42 no
I was I was okay I was 42 as a starter
okay but we've actually lost we lost the
game before I started my first game so
took us a loss for me to become sorry
basically also if you don't lose that
game you don't start oh it was a game
before the bye week and you know I was
young I had just moved to a new school
and I think they were just trying to
give me you know I committed to the
offense you know working through some
things and then that tragedy kind of
happened we don't lose a lot down
infection so you know he just kind of
shook things up and then after that I
think it was just unnecessary
now when you go to Texas A&M originally
you're sort of hailed as the next Johnny
Manziel is that what the headlines are
that some of the articles about you I
think you know I think the ability that
I have kind of gave that spark you know
and then he had been there you know well
I think two years before I got there and
you know Aggieland was pretty was
popping at the time so yeah I think you
know everybody had a hope that I would
go to do the same thing but when you
visited did you meet him
I actually met Johnny at a lead 11 camp
in Dallas it was at the Cowboys facility
the first elemental when did you know
that you could play in a high level
football high school you know growing up
I knew I wouldn't be the tallest guy so
I actually didn't really I didn't
believe you know the one a lot of school
quarterbacks at the time you know at the
high level so I didn't think you know
I'd be one of those high recruited guys
I thought I'd always have to you know
kind of work my way up to the top and go
go go to a lower college and pretty much
this ball from there and you know just
proved everybody that I could do it at a
high level so but I also believe you
know at high school home is when I
believe that and I kind of gained the
confidence I've always had a confidence
but confidence with me be able to do it
this low who's your idol who did you
look up to my idol as far as in any
sport or just let's do football all
right football now I love Russell but I
think the way the way Tom Brady just I
think his leadership and your high
carries himself he's just smooth guys at
all times and I'm not a situation he's
clutch I think I think Tom Brady's a guy
if you could ask him one question what
would you ask Brady
well that's great for so long it's weird
though because you're as athletic as
anybody who plays this position and he's
not very athletic so
could you beat Brady in a 40-yard dash
running backwards
he runs forward yeah probably yeah I
think so yeah
who is your baseball I know baseball
growing up I played infield and often
many people are familiar with uh Jose
Reyes my my favorite player growing up
really yeah I was a Mets fan just using
pins oh god oh yeah yeah I was how did
you didn't somebody try to steer you
away from being a Mets fan although they
did go to the world I'm trying to think
when you would have fallen in love with
the Mets when they were actually good
ten years ago yeah yeah why you play
with you know you played shortstop as
well so I just kind of just clicked
what's tougher college football or
college baseball college football cause
baseball uh I know pretty hard it's not
easy to do I mean at this level you know
baseball baseball is a game of failure
and you know the year before this past
year I didn't have a very good season so
I think oh I think baseball is a harder
game in general well when you fall like
if I said we could watch the Oakland A's
play a baseball game or watch
Dallas Cowboys play a football game and
we had to decide what we're just
watching like what do you love why would
you watch football watch the football
game okay but you're gonna be playing
baseball for a living yeah yep oh but do
you love do you love football more than
baseball even though you might be more
successful at baseball or have a longer
career in baseball I mean I love both
it's not the question if I love both
it's just you know there are two
different games I can't really know but
I can't really explain it you know
unless unless you just play both of this
level
you really really don't know yeah best
way I can put it let's just I just
football you know you get the rush of
running out to a hundred thousand people
and then baseball you got maybe maybe
five thousand people watching you that's
another thing you you probably play in
stadiums that weren't as good as the
stadium you had in high school
exactly yeah how many how many seats
how many fans at a alman high school
football game what did I want to say
seventeen sixteen eighteen thousand you
know we squeezed in like twenty thousand
at times and then you know state
championship games and cowboys and
Jerry's probably the most I think was
like fifty six thousand something like
that yeah weird I mean I guess yeah not
crazy it's pretty crazy so if you go out
in front of a hundred thousand I mean
what's what's a hundred if you played in
front of 50 right but some atmospheres
are a little different
he's Kyler Murray yeah you can call him
k1 if you want you will use the Oklahoma
Sooners quarterback how good was your
dad at am i believe i believe he's
pretty good though applause you know
we've grown up I've seen it all all the
games so yeah I wish you know I wish
he'd never get he never got hurt I feel
like you know he's had a great great
shot in the NFL but things everything
happens for a reason you know I think
it's pretty good though you know Texas
A&M Hall of Famer at what point did you
become better than your dad I don't know
I'm so striving to be I can be um you
know I'm not really I don't know you
tell you never but and I think I'm I
think I'm alright right now when do you
know that coach Riley is upset with you
well not know um I don't think you just
upset of me a lot
your numbers I can understand that and
25% for interceptions but has he been
upset at you does he yell at you he
honestly hasn't really um I think he's
the most mad he's gonna be the season
probably's for just just me making her
that you know I know when supposed to
bake and I kind of try to setup all in a
certain area that was what I yeah I mean
between me and him yeah this not really
much couldn't get angry I mean for the
most part I keep it that way
what's the Heisman Trophy mean to you
Heisman Trophy um something I've dreamed
of as a kid man growing up you know
playing CWI football you know Xbox and
stuff like that I'm I've dreamt of that
wonder husband my whole life so if I was
if I was able to do that here it'd mean
a lot to me I know it's been a lot of
universities in the sense my family
especially with bake doing it last year
I think it'd be pretty special
how often do you uh Tech's stay in touch
with Baker Mayfield oh yeah big bake is
a base my boy um we don't talk a lot
right now just because you know what
most kind of busy I know he's busy up
there in Cleveland tough losses past
weekend by the way but um ya know we
don't talk too much but uh you know I
think we both understand that it's a
mutual thing and you know he knows I'm
ready to go every Saturday I know he's
ready to go every Sunday so uh that's
just kind of where we're at right now
have you practiced the Heisman pose okay
not all right if I said you had to go
against Baker Mayfield in a throwing
contest or a dancing contest
oh no choose both really he really
thinks he can dance I know he does I
don't know why to dance with you got you
guys
he's got more more rhythm than most but
it's there's a little stiffness in there
well he was trying to get me to help him
be a backup dancer for Justin Timberlake
and that was his dream yeah you got a
session with Justin yeah he was he was
like God can you can you do that can you
hook me up I said I can see I don't know
how good you I've seen a couple of these
dances if you want to call it that but
it feels like Justin jigs gonna ask a
little bit more but hey congrats so far
on the season and you know good luck
with your professional career and good
luck running the table there with the
Sooners Thank You Kyler we appreciate
your time good kid k1 his dad was really
good but you start out at A&M you're the
next Johnny Manziel and then all of a
sudden end up at Oklahoma and you follow
Baker Mayfield jr. at the third leads
gone pretty well for four more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]